hey welcome back to our series on using
G suite developer tools for student
developers in this segment we'll look at
using G suite rest APs along with code
samples
I'm your host Wesley Chun if you missed
the overview video check it out first
because there we show you how to get
started getting credentials and creating
projects using G suite api's now we're
gonna dive in starting with Google Drive
here's code that lists the first 100
files and folders in your Google Drive
believe it or not the real application
is really just the last three lines
everything else is just the security
boilerplate we covered earlier plus the
requested scopes and API endpoint
creation once you have an endpoint to
the drive API it's as simple as creating
a file listing query executing that
query and displaying the results if you
want to build this app line by line
check out the code lab heads up google's
upgrading to newer client libraries to
bring the GCP and g-suit worlds closer
together while the current libraries
will stay operational for a while you
need to see how the code changes so
here's the exact same example but with
the newer libraries as you can see aside
from a couple of import changes managing
the OAuth tokens yourself everything
else stays mostly the same the G sweet
ducks already reflect this change but
bear in mind that most of the code in
the wild still uses the original
libraries including the deep dive video
linked here while this sample is in
Python you can guess that the client
library operates like this apply
regardless of what language you use okay
now that you've seen some code let's
take a step back and think why you would
use the drive API
oh one reason could be you want to write
an app that backs up zip files but
expands them in flight to Google Drive
well this is an actual JavaScript sample
app check out its open source repo if
interested another example let's say you
get a job at a startup helping people
automate photo albums well you pitch
that everyone who gets back from
vacation have to empty out their cameras
and phones to an external hard drive and
what did all those pictures look like on
disk a big and organized mess right but
if you use the drive API to access file
metadata like the timestamp in
geolocation you and your team could
actually build an app that auto
generates photo albums now taking a step
further stitch those photos together
into a video
upload it with the YouTube API then use
the Gmail API to tell your friends and
family get an idea of what you can do
with Google API s now it's as limitless
as your imagination
each Google API has official
documentation and the G sweet ones live
at developers.google.com/live is such as
drive the docs are structured via a
guides tab that feature quick starts in
multiple languages as well as guides for
specific API features now beyond the
quick starts are more fully fleshed out
sample apps these live under the samples
tab for each API and links to any open
source repos or developer videos now if
you need help the support tab links to
Stack Overflow or issue tracker for bugs
and feature requests or perhaps
communities of like-minded developers
next let's move to the sheets API after
all aren't spreadsheets the most
programmable of all the productivity
apps you may have data sitting in a
database or a CSV file but those form
factors aren't exactly visually
appealing right do you really want to
tell your boss to select star from your
database while spreadsheets are common
and simple user interface that feature
tabular data and JavaScript developers
can try the API code lab that lets you
build a customized reporting tool for a
fictitious toy manufacturer now in this
code sample we're going to reuse that
toy order database and migrate it to a
spreadsheet again the OAuth code will be
the same as before but switch to the
sheets rewrite scope and its API
endpoint now as you can see the first
half of the code snippet queries for the
toy order data while the second half
creates a new sheet and pushes the data
there check out the video for more on
this sample don't forget to enable the
API first moving on why the slides API
well the same reason as sheets but
taking it a step further
yes sheets is definitely more visual
than a database but isn't a slide act
the ultimate in visualization or maybe
you're organizing your school's
hackathon and want to create only one
master slide deck when seeking corporate
sponsorships or you're a salesperson
who's giving the same pitch to multiple
clients well why not create one master
template deck then auto-generate
systemized X for each sponsor or
customer now here's that code snippet
replacing the placeholder variables with
actual data whether it's the customer
name or corporate logo now this one's
also got a video for further study in
real life you can probably guess this
isn't the whole thing and you will need
to use more than one API well think
about it don't you have to call the
drive API to copy the master template
then get the customer or sponsor
information from the sheets API then
generate the slide deck with the slides
API
well this pseudocode answers the obvious
question of how to set up using more
than one API at a time now here's
another example using two api's here we
take data and a chart from a spreadsheet
and add them to a slide deck the video
also shows how to read the data from the
sheets API first now the docs API is a
perfect tool for creating a mail merge
tool similar to the customer slide decks
let's say you got a form letter with
variable placeholders like this then you
have a sheet with the data for each
recipient well here's the heart of the
mail merge code look how similar it is
to the slides example once you copy the
master template doc and read the data
from the sheet it's not much effort to
fill in those variable placeholders now
this video doesn't go over the code but
you can get a link to the apps open
source repo once it's done executing you
should have an individual Google Doc
with all the substitutions made all you
need to do is call the drive API to
export it as PDF then build an email
message with this attachment and then
send it with the Gmail API
alright so that's our quick tour of G
suite REST API s to learn more about
others check out our landing page in the
next episode we'll cover a higher-level
platform that lets you access G suite
api's with just objects and not have to
worry as much about authorization code
join us as we tell you about Google Apps
Script this is Wesley Chun from Google
and we'll see you next time
you
[Music]
you